no Taylor
I'm really happy for you I'm let you
finish but Beyonce had one of the best
videos of all time
Kanye West's Interruption of Taylor
Swift's acceptance speech at the MTV
Video Music Awards was shocking but
crazy Antics like this are par for the
course for Kanye West it's just Kanye
being Kanye yet that moment in 2009 is
nothing compared to his latest
controversies Kanye West has
single-handedly destroyed all that he
has worked so hard to achieve the final
nail in the coffin came just after Elon
Musk lifted his ban and he was welcomed
back to Twitter he then got himself
kicked off again after tweeting out a
photo of a swastika symbol inside a star
of David which we've blurred because
it's not appropriate to show musk said
the rapper violated the platform's rule
against prohibiting incitement to
violence Kanye's career is officially up
in flames and you can forget about him
running for president in 2024 not that
anyone took him seriously his Fall From
Grace has actually been years in the
making in 2018 things appeared to be
going well for Kanye West he seemed
happy with his wife Kim Kardashian and
Was preparing to release a new album but
take a closer look and there were
noticeable cracks his album yay was
delayed repeatedly before finally being
released to less than glowing reviews
he would officially change his name to
just yay with no last name there were
indications on the album cover of yay
that something wasn't quite right he
apparently snapped this photo of the
mountains in Wyoming on his iPhone and
scribbled the words I hate being bipolar
it's awesome
Kanye was diagnosed with bipolar
disorder in 2016. according to the
American Psychiatric association people
with a mental illness can experience
intense emotional states which can
result in Risky Behavior yay's State of
Mind was pretty evident
after his flurry of anti-Semitic posts
on Instagram which got removed he took
to Twitter to lash chat an Instagram CEO
Mark Zuckerberg but then he got banned
on Twitter in December and switched back
to Instagram where he bizarrely accused
musk of being a half-chinese genetic
hybrid
the same week he got booted from Twitter
he appeared on conspiracy theorist Alex
Jones Show wearing a full black mask in
which he made it known that he liked
Hitler in that he had a lot of redeeming
qualities and he denied the Holocaust
ever happened
some even remarked that he made Alex
Jones look sane for once he kept up the
full face mask look for a subsequent
interview on sensor.tv it's like how
many times do I have to prove oh how
many times I have to do something like
so miraculous for people to see that
it's brilliant and it's that mental
health like me wearing a mask
gives me this ability to not have to
worry about showing my face so I can
think about what I'm saying and I can
Channel there was also the time he
recently stormed off political
commentator Tim Poole's podcast after
pool appeared to challenge his negative
views of Jewish people are you leaving
he went out the door and so it seems has
his entire career he's on it would take
a miracle for him to make a comeback
after all that's happened and he's
already been gifted a miracle once
before when he nearly died in 2002 after
a late night at a studio in California
he fell asleep at the wheel and collided
with another vehicle shattering his jaw
his jaw was wired to his face during
reconstructive surgery which inspired
his hit single Through the Wire up until
then he had been boxed in as a producer
and was never taken seriously as a
rapper but the car crash hit him with a
burst of creativity
2004 debut album College Dropout
received critical Acclaim with tracks
like Jesus walks and then he kept Rising
his sixth studio album Jesus was out of
this world
seemed Unstoppable and so apparently was
his ego he called himself the next Steve
Jobs a Visionary at one point he was
believed to be the wealthiest musician
on the planet Forbes estimated that he
had a net worth of 2 billion in 2022
before it all came crashing down Adidas
stopped selling his Yeezy sneakers
because of his anti-semitic rants Gap
cut ties with him so did Balenciaga the
fashion house he controversially stood
up for when it launched an ad campaign
with children holding teddy bears in
bondage gear behind the eyebrow raising
rants lay a troubled man whose manic
episodes had concerned his then wife in
2020 Kim Kardashian posted an Instagram
story about his bipolar disorder for the
first time quote anyone who has this or
has a loved one in their life who does
knows how incredibly complicated and
painful it is to understand
she said she felt the need to speak out
publicly because of the stigma and
misconceptions about mental health
Kardashian also mentioned that the
painful loss of his mother greatly
affected it
Kanye was incredibly close to his mum Dr
Dondo West an English professor at
Chicago State University she died
unexpectedly of a heart attack in 2007
at the age of just 58 after getting
several cosmetic surgeries he named his
2021 album after her the album had no
cover art it was simply a black Square
Kardashian ended her Instagram post by
pleading that the media and the public
give her family the compassion and
empathy needed to get through this
instead of the spotlight instead of
being surrounded by people telling him
how great he was instead of Fame Fortune
and fans Kanye needed help
it's difficult to see someone go from
the highest of highs to the lowest of
lows his breakdown has caused him to
lose everything that our society seems
to cherish Fortune power status
influence Kim and Kanye also split in
2021 after six years of marriage and
four children
Kanye West has a song on his fifth album
called Lost in the world it begins with
the lyrics I'm up in the woods I'm down
on my mind I'm building a still
to slow down the time
it's about those who want to stop and
clear their minds Define themselves
perhaps a lesson for himself
with a controversy surrounding him and
Brands dropping him left right and
Center Kanye West is reportedly no
longer a billionaire many billionaires
have found alternative ways to grow
their wealth with the stock market
looking shaky a recent survey found 9
out of 10 financial advisors are
branching out from the typical portfolio
of stocks in bonds my sponsor
Masterworks offers a unique asset that
the Uber Rich have invested in and now
you can too I'm talking about art
contemporary art has outpaced the S P
500 by 131 percent over the last 26
years with Masterworks you can invest in
legendary art from Picasso basquia
Banksy by buying shares in these works
so you don't have to spend Millions on
their paintings six of Masterworks 9
recent sales delivered a net return to
investors of over 21 percent demand is
so high Masterworks is looking to
acquire new artwork every week nearly
600 000 people have signed up so far
including many of my viewers so there is
a wait list but you can get Priority
Access by signing up with my custom link
in the description thanks for watching
for newsthink I'm Cindy Palm